very pleased to see the former Justice
Minister and of course Rishi sunak
supporter Victoria Atkins joins us on
the program Ms Jackson it's lovely to
see you and first things first can we
get a guarantee that we're not all going
to be back here in a few months time
electing another conservative leader and
prime minister
uh yes because uh
Rishi got
get together as members of parliament to
debate the great issues of the day the
reception which she got from across the
party was so uh inspiring to see and
also so comforting when you look at the
range of supporters across the party I
think we have a real chance here of you
lighting and the reason we want to unite
is because we realize the very very
grave issues facing the country indeed
and all of us all of us whatever side of
the party we come from all of us want to
unite to work together to deliver for
our country and our constituents with
respect that's exactly what those trust
supporters told me seven weeks ago today
they went too far too far too fast with
some of the measures that were announced
I wanted desperately wanted Liz to
succeed I'm a conservative I also want
to deliver for my constituents but I
think now that we've seen the reaction
of the markets and also there has been a
much greater debate as to the
precariousness of the world economy as
well as our own domestic economy economy
I I think and I'm convinced given the
reaction of members of parliament
yesterday and the unity that people
showed in uniting behind Rishi that we
will be able to move forward yeah we're
elected by our construction to deliver
we want to do that
I mean presumably you're not talking
about people like Nadine Doris who says
a general election is now necessary
presumably you're not talking about
another end piece of Christopher chope
suggesting that uh that British sunak
supporters are hyenas uh certainly not
Mr Campbell Bannerman who Twisted a
picture last night of a snake on the
doorstep of number 10 with Rishi sunak's
face this doesn't strike me as a party
in the throes of unity
now I mean the last chap you mentioned
just then isn't a member of parliament
but um
yeah there are going to be uh look we
understand this is a it's been a very
very tough uh six weeks for us as a
party of course the country would be
saying well hang on a minute it's been a
very tough six weeks for us as well
which is why I think of course there
will be some bruised feelings among some
people but actually what we saw
yesterday was the overwhelming majority
of people coming together understanding
that we now have to focus on tackling
inflation we have to stabilize the
markets we have to try to help the bank
of England with the the difficult
decisions they have coming ahead of them
with interest rates and so on we have to
do everything we can to stabilize the
economy because if we can do that then
we can start to deliver the vision that
Rishi set out over the summer and that
we will all look forward to supporting
when there is a general election
sure there will however be people
watching this morning who do not simply
believe what you see because of the
destabilizing effect that the
conservatives have laterally had on on
the economy so so just in terms of
policy what is Rishi sunat going to do
to deal with that 40 odd billion pound
black hole as identified by pretty much
every Financial commentator I can find
well the first I'm very very conscious
that we need to regain people's trust
and so uh Rishi being the former
Chancellor that he is don't forget he uh
set up the furlough scheme had to deal
with the nightmare of the coveted
pandemic within a month of becoming
Chancellor he managed it superbly and
said we knew all of that what is he
going to do about the black hole so in
terms of the black hole he will be
getting to work immediately with the
chancellor to address these issues
you'll you'll appreciate I'm not in the
room with them in those discussions
indeed but my goodness me we have a we
have someone in office who doesn't need
um lessons in how the you know how the
treasury works or whatever he will
absolutely get on with the job as soon
as he walks through that great big black
door but are there areas that should be
protected the health service for example
the three percent on on defense spending
well we um again Rishi has said that we
stood and and won an election in 2019 on
that Manifesto and he wants to stick to
that Manifesto and that seems to me uh
absolutely the right way forward and so
we're committed completely committed to
the NHS we know that this winter is
going to be a very difficult one for a
whole host of reasons not least the
backlogs that accumulated during the as
a result of the pandemic but also with
defense he's been very very clear that
for example we will continue to do
everything we need to do not just to
defend our country but also to help
Ukraine in particular which of course
that war that Dreadful war in Ukraine is
some of the reason for some of the
economic turmoil that the whole world is
seeing as a result of energy prices
escalating
but but we are going to be entering into
aren't we a period of austerity and it
will be a period of austerity in which
we have a prime minister who via
marriage is a billionaire so when Rishi
sunak stands up and says that there
isn't going to be any money to give
nurses to put their salaries up that
there isn't going to be money to pay for
school repairs or perhaps even some
covert compliance ventilation going on
in there it will be a billionaire saying
so how do you think the public will
react to that
so if I can just stack a little bit from
that because um as I say it wouldn't be
right for me to appear even by inference
to confirm
um what you're saying in that question I
think we've got to give Rishi and the
chancellor a bit of time and space to
work out the plans where you know Rishi
very much would once the a statement to
go ahead on 31st of October but
decisions will be made on that we've got
to take this step by step in terms of
how Rishi uh speaks the public
communicates with the public relates to
the public I think we saw it again in
the pandemic you know I'm not asking you
to imagine that he's good at this we
know he's good at this because we've
seen it as we were all huddled around
our televisions during lockdown and
we're reassured by Rishi saying this is
what I'm going to do for you we're going
to put our arms around you and so I'm
very very confident that we will see
more of Rishi in that mode if you like
reassuring us stabilizing the markets
and it is notable by the way the
reaction of the markets over the last 24
hours I think that again gives us some
small grounds for optimism and so I
think stabilizing the markets tackling
inflation because as Rishi said
throughout the summer that is the killer
with a lot of this you know if we've got
food inflation if we've got wage
inflation these are all difficult
difficult issues and Rishi has the
experience and the expertise to deal
with this
all of which makes whoever he puts
around the cabinet table with them
incredibly incredibly important
particularly of course the job in number
11. he's talked about building a
government of all the talents what do
you understand him to mean by that I
mean are we basically not going to about
to see a member of the ERG sitting
around the cabinet table
I think we have an enormous range of
talents across the party I'm not going
to name names if you'll forgive me
because I I don't want to make enemies
at seven o'clock in the morning but uh
fair enough now yeah but we have a huge
range of talent across the party and I
think one of the um sadnesses of uh
perhaps the last six weeks was that not
all of that Talent was really used and
really exploited if you like um by the
previous administration so I'm really
looking forward to some excellent
colleagues and we've got we've got a
huge range of experience in teaching
police and and so on across the board
I'd love to see some of our expertise
and experience come into our government
so that we're shaping policies and
delivering policies that really make a
difference for our country
meet the case then if you can for the
country not being given a vote on what
is you know the the third prime minister
we've had in you know a handful of
months why is no not the right time I
mean you've gone through the decision
breaking process now twice internally
within the conservative party by your
own admission you got it wrong the first
time you know you're keeping your
fingers crossed on this one I mean why
not a little more than that you know
forgive me a little bit more than that
I'm very confident about uh this
Administration uh in terms of demand I
think there are two actually two primary
reasons first of all it's completely
practical which is my goodness me we
have got a lot to deal with at the
moment we have to stabilize the markets
we have to stabilize the economy we have
to ensure for example that the energy
price guarantee that Liz introduced
that's a phenomenal package that would
make sense that would make sense that
would make sense if the first thing I
said to his MPS was not unite or die I
mean this is all about the existential
crisis the conservative party is facing
it's nothing to do with country
no no and the second reason if I may for
um the the question about an election
and forgive me this is a bit of sort of
constitutional uh law in the in the
middle of the beginning of the morning
for people who've just woken up but uh
we do we elect we let elect a party you
know it's a conservative Manifesto in
2019. uh we don't have a presidential
system and I am responsible and uh I am
representative of my constituents but
I'm also accountable to them so we stood
on that Manifesto we deliver it and of
course in Parliament it is the let's
trust did not deliver the 2019 Manifesto
who can command a majority and and His
Majesty the king will invite uh that
person to deliver a government look I
think I mean again I think Liz would
accept that she stepped away from the
2019 Manifesto there were particular
issues that's my point why should we no
believe you that Rishi sunai will not I
mean the last prime minister that was in
post for seven weeks said exactly the
same thing you know Cameron give us my
plan put it to the country but so what's
the difference I mean you've already
shown that the conservative party cannot
be trusted to the 2019 Manifesto
commitment with the last well current
prime minister because because Rishi
said we will stick to the 2019 Manifesto
it's as simple as that so yeah we will
continue to see the focus on leveling up
we'll continue to see the focus on the
NHS on on security my own personal area
of sort of expertise and interest if you
will is supporting violence or attacking
violence against women girls supporting
victims of domestic abuse and so on we
want to continue all of these pieces of
work as we deal with this very very
difficult issue of our domestic economy
in the context of the international
problems that other countries are facing
as well so look I appreciate that it's
been a pretty you know it's been a
brutal six weeks in politics for lots of
people it's been a very very fast pace
but we now behind Rishi will have a
stability and confidence and reassurance
that I hope will begin to make a real
difference to people's lives over the
coming weeks and months
I I know I've got to let you go but I
can't let let you go without this cheeky
little question at the end have you got
a job
[Laughter]
yeah indeed okay Victoria Atkins lovely
to have you on the program Take Care
thank you so much take care